Let's do another example. This is Santa Clara County in California. And let's
say that the mean rent for apartments is 1,830 for all types of units. A
certain rental company called Rental California owns and rents a lot of
apartments. And they want to know if the amount they're renting it for is
significantly different than this population mean. So they examine a random
sample of their own units of size 25. They find that on average, they rent each
unit out for 1,700. And the sample standard deviation was $200. You're going to
conduct a one sample t-test for them. Here are the null and alternative
hypothesis, and remember, they're concerned with whether or not it's
significantly different. Even though they found that it's less, this will still
be the alternative hypothesis. And they also want an alpha level of 0.05. First
of all, find a t critical values for a two-tailed test at alpha equals 0.05.
Put them here and here.